a second shark attack in three days hit  a florida beach community known as the  shark bite capital of the world  eighteen-year-old reid Zipporah was  bitten at new samara beach yesterday  while surfing photo show blood on the  beach near his surfboard zipper needed  19 stitches on his left hand  coincidentally a friend with him also  was bitten by a shark several years ago  it's kind of crazy cuz like I came back  out here with my buddy Reid and it's  like the same thing happened again so it  definitely shows how many sharks are out  here video captured a shark attacking  another surfer Saturday in Jacksonville  Beach blood could be seen on his elbow  right around the bite that attack plus 2  at Newsome erina Beach means three  people overall were bitten within 72  hours along Florida's coast oh alright